[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live la date du
15 mai est elle selon vous table pour
les 1ère levée de restrictions
sanitaires c'est la question qu'on vous
pose ce soir sur twitter on est là pour
en débattre vous avez raison d'être avec
nous parce que sur ce plateau il y a
deux femmes exceptionnelles ce soir
bonsoir lucidi schmidt alors on rappelle
que vous êtes outre et vous êtes
exceptionnel cofondatrice de la fabrique
écologique ancien élu écologiste
justement est socialiste et membre du
comité de rédaction de la passionnante
revue esprit et avec vous ce soit avec
nous et eugénie bastié donc on est
content de recevoir et de revoir sur le
plateau de filles là et sur le plateau
de point de vue journaliste au service
débat opinion du figaro doit-on le
rappeler et on signale on recommande
bien entendu votre dernier livre une
passionnante enquête
la guerre des idées au coeur des
batailles intellectuelle actuelle c'est
assez difficile de réussir ce qu'a
réussi le génie c'est à dire à la fois
un exposé clair sur et érudit sur les
différents champs de bataille à
intellectuels d'aujourd'hui est
également et bien d'en faire le récit
d'en faire une investigation et ça se
lit comme un roman et on apprend
énormément de choses sur les trois
critiques de mai 68 en particulier ou
bien les batailles sociologique
notamment entre bourdieu et boudon
en cause exacte reste donc la notamment
notamment sa et donc c'est absolument à
lire tout comme un état lire la dernière
publication que vous avez vu de la revue
esprit
alors justement revenir sur un des
aspects de la bataille intellectuelle
débat d'une des batailles intellectuelle
darde ses champs de bataille avec les
tweets polémique de la firme evian ou
des séminaires de des blanchiments chez
coca cola les grandes entreprises sont
elles devenues les vecteurs de
l'idéologie hook
eh bien on va en débattre et donner
peut-être la définition pour ceux qui
l'ignorent de ce qu'est le walkie isme
ce soir à 18 heures il ya deux
événements d'abord lucile schmid va
revenir on va remettre le prix du roman
écologique à une à une ou à lauréats
dont on ne peut pas dire pour l'instant
le nom mais en moins on fait le teaser
la réponse vers 18h15 vous nous la
donnerait lui s'il est en tous les cas
le louvre âge récompensé est assez
passionnant et
assez amusant tous les cas au niveau 2
au niveau du titre je n'en dis pas plus
pendant ce temps il y aura un réunion à
l'elysée pour parler des confinement une
petite musique d'ailleurs montre dans
les médias c'est la remise en cause du
15 mai comme horizon de levée des
restrictions
alors en attendant sent bien que par
contres à bercy on s'impatiente
voici ce qu'en dit le ministre
d'économie bruno le maire je souhaite
évidemment que la réouverture se fasse
sur des bases solides et base sanitaire
solide qui sécurise le client et qui
nous garantisse que ensuite on n'est pas
forcé à refermer à nouveau spots et ce
bien entendu donc le 15 mai fait partie
des hypothèses mais pas une hypothèse
privilégiée semble-t-il par olivier faur
le premier secrétaire du ps semblent
plus enclins à lui à écouter les
alarmistes
voici en tout cas le conseil qu'il donne
à emmanuel macron il doit fixer un
horizon donné un agenda et puis après
ils tenir compte aussi d'une réalité qui
est une réalité dure très dure il faut
qu' on est des éléments qu'ils soient
des éléments probants et qu'on soit
protégée et qu'on n'est pas qu'on
n'ouvre pas à nouveau la bergerie au
loup
ne pas ouvrir de nouveau la bergerie au
lui lucile quel est votre votre point de
vue est ce que vous partagez plus tôt le
point de vue de ceux qui veulent tenir
finalement le cap du 15 mai ou bien
écouter cette musique qui montrent
d'ailleurs que on peut pas aujourd'hui
fixer une date et puis de toute façon ça
va être très difficile de tenir cette
date
est ce que j'ai le droit de faire une
réponse de normand c'est à dire que j'ai
13 ans vous avez tous les droits j'ai
très envie que le cap fixé la date
surtout qui a été donné par emmanuel
macron soient tenues c'est à dire que
j'ai très envie que le déconfinement
puisse avoir lieu le 15 mai je vois bien
qu'il ya des incertitudes et même des
menaces qui tiennent notamment variant
brésilien c'est à dire que la la réalité
c'est que au moins ce qui ressort des
deux interventions qu'on a regardé
emmanuel macron n'est pas responsable de
tout il est pas responsable du variant
brésilien il est pas responsable du
variant anglais il est responsable
d'avoir choisi d'afficher une date alors
même qu'ils avaient plusieurs dates qui
ont été affichées au fur et à mesure
qu'on a été confiné des confiné et c'est
donc d'avoir pris le risque d'afficher
une date
il est tout à fait normal que le
gouvernement et président de la
république tienne le cap qu'ils ont
affichée après si on s'aperçoit qu'au
niveau des hôpitaux de la stratégie de
vaccination les choses ne suivent pas le
rythme ce qui m'a semblé intéressant
dans la dernière intervention des
manuels macron c'est qu'il n'avait pas
lu brice habituels qu'on a vu l'arrogant
où on a vu du côté politique et qu'au
contraire il a fait des mea culpa donc
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
qu'ils tiennent la tonalité de cette
modestie relative qu'il avait affichée
et qu'en même temps il y a une grande
détermination et aussi en matière
sanitaire c'est à dire que sur le
variant brésilien par exemple moi je
trouve que les critiques qui sont faites
sur la stratégie française sur le fait
qu'il faudrait faire une quarantaine
obligatoire des gens qui arrivent du
brésil
et les zones dans lesquelles il ya des
variants c'est une critique très forte
il faut faire attention à ce que
factuellement sur le sanitaire on se
contente pas de dire les choses vont
bien se passer parce qu'il n'y a plus
d'avion qui arrive du brésil oui moi je
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer le 15
mai en tout cas je sais qu'il faut qu'il
se passe quelque chose c'est à dire qu'
il va falloir un moment ouvrir un peu le
couvercle parce que l'offre il faut
rappeler quand même que de ça fait
depuis le 17 octobre 2020 6 mois que
nous sommes en couvre-feu en france
nous aurait dit ça il ya un an n'aurait
trouvé ça invraisemblable de même qu'on
aurait trouvé un vraisemblable qu'ils
essaient en mille morts à la fin
d'épidémie
c'est sûr que c'était fini a pris une
ampleur qu'on avait tous plus ou moins
sous-estimé au début mais je crois qu'on
est passé par différentes phases
et si on revient par exemple un an en
arrière le premier compliment en fait
l'inquiétude sanitaire surplombe et où
la peur sur plan b tout le deuxième
confinement en octobre c'était
l'inquiétude économique qui était
beaucoup mis en avant comme en affaires
pour maintenir l'économie enfin il faut
absolument faire quelque chose pour les
commerces etc
et finalement c'était plus la colère je
trouve qu'ils étaient dans l'ambiance du
moment
hélas ce troisième confinement j'ai
l'impression que c'est l'inquiétude
psychologique qui prédomine non plus
sanitaires ni économique et
psychologique avec c'est une forme de
résignation collective
après la peur après la colère la
résignation et je trouve ce climat très
très mal ça en réalité parce que même
quand il ya de la colère au moins il ya
il ya des gens il ya l élan et à
l'opposition on propose des choses
concrètes j'en disais d'arbres et là il
ya un espèce de personnes ne se dire
qu'il faudrait ouvrir personne n'ose
dire qu'il faut
enfin nous de mettre en oeuvre des
alternatives et je trouve que le climat
est absolument délétère avec
effectivement la mise en avant d'une
souffrance psychologique qui commence à
être intenable dans certaines parties de
la population
oui juste un point quand même pour vous
relancer les cils on voit que variant
brésiliens ou variant anglais ou pas
d'abord la grande bretagne a réouvert et
enfin tous les cas rouvre ses terrasses
il ya des allègements notamment dans la
suisse voisine également en italie qui
s'annonce
est-ce que du coup cela plaiderait pas
en faveur de justement de tenir et de
maintenir ce cap du 15 mai ah mais moi
je suis pour maintenir ce cap après je
pense qu'il ya plusieurs contradictions
à résoudre c'est à dire que par exemple
ceux qui auraient envie de pouvoir se
déconfit n'est qu'ils sont très nombreux
mais quand vous regardez la liste qui a
été mise en place par deux médecins
qu'aux vidy liste de gens qui ne sont
pas prioritaires pour se vacciner il ya
cinq cent mille personnes inscrites
il arrive à faire vacciner avec des
fonds de 12 mille deux mille personnes
mais ça illustre le fait qu'il ya une
envie de se vacciner pour pouvoir sortir
ça me semble assez clair c'est pas une
envie de se vacciner pour se vacciner
ça c'est un premier point mais ils se
trouvent quatre ou cinq il ya beaucoup
de pression d'ailleurs pour certains
pour qu'ils soient vaccinés pour qu'ils
aient l'autorisation de sortir notamment
dans les ehpad
en tout cas cette question de pouvoir
retrouver la liberté de vivre est
quelque chose qu'on ressent fortement
mais on a le sentiment que le dire c'est
déjà là je rejoins un génie presque
quelque chose de provocateur
parce que au fond et là dessus on peut
peut-être parler moi je ne suis pas
journaliste mais on peut peut-être dire
qu'il ya une diffusion par les médias de
cette angoisse cette inquiétude c'est à
dire que quelque part il faut nourrir la
bête chaque jour il ya un nouveau
variant il ya est ce que vous croyez
vraiment que le 15 mai on pourra sortir
et au fond les ministres c'est frappant
de voir comment bruno le maire doit à
chaque fois lutter contre le fait qu'on
lui dise mais alors qu écouter on est le
15 avril
mais le 15 mai ça sera pas tenable alors
moi je pense qu'il ya plusieurs choses
pour l'exécutif
c'est la stratégie vaccinale est là
dessus la question d'astrazeneca par
exemple est un vrai sujet c'est à dire
qu' il semble admis maintenant que si on
veut se faire vacciner
il faut avoir le vaccin chic le files
ou le moderna il faut surtout pas avoir
le vaccin de deuxième zone
et ça c'est un problème c'est à dire
qu'il faut rectifier le tir là dessus
très très remuant la stratégie sanitaire
et tenir un discours autoritaire là
dessus sur la santé alors que c'est lui
donc de la revue esprit qui plaide en
faveur d'un discours autoritaire on note
en tout c'est une grave accident là sur
la vaccination les écus tiff à la peur
et le traumatisme du premier des
compliments auxquels on a attribué à mon
avis à tort à la reprise de l'épidémie
en disant qu'on avait des conflits nés
trop vite il y avait eu trop de
terrasses de café ouverte
c'est vrai que vu la pression des
restaurateurs font dès maintenant on
ouvre parce qu'il y avait très peu de
cas est en réalité ce qui est l'échec en
a il n'a pas été celui de la réouverture
trop rapide mais de là l'échec de la
stratégie tester tracé isolé qui n'a pas
été bien mis en place puisqu'on se
souvient personne n'arrive à sion a
testé on avait les résultats des tests
une semaine parfois après s'être fait
tester ce qui servait à rien parce que
les gens du coup de dissimuler le virus
personne n'a jamais mis en place
franchement en france une stratégie
d'isolement des deux jambes pour ce père
isolé moi même j'ai une vie et le comité
de semaine pour recevez un appel de de
l'assurance maladie vous a fait déjà une
semaine voire dix jours que vous allez
coheed qui m'ont dit on peut vous aider
à faire vos courses si vous voulez c'est
toujours voilà un peu un problème est en
fait le jeu je pense que pour penser de
déconfinement il faut vraiment penser
sérieusement se donner les moyens de
cette stratégie et être assez isolé
et parce que la vaccination on voit bien
qu'on n'a pas les moyens d'aller aussi
vite qu'on le voudrait et je pense qu'un
deuxième levier et qui est peu qui a peu
été employé en france qui est celui de
de repousser dans le temps la deuxième
dose ce qui a été fait au royaume uni
et cap et en voyons ici à 60% de la
population 70 % la population qui est
vaccinée c'est en réalité très peu de
gens on dose réalise que 11 % de la
population qui a reçu les deux doses
voilà qui est le double de la france
marqué dans la france n'était pas non
plus les contrôles et en fait ils ont
fait ce choix là en mettant à 12
semaines la deuxième dose nous on a
commencé à le faire parce qu'on a
allongé à six semaines
la deuxième dose de pfizer est en fait
ça permettrait quand même deux de gagner
potentiellement plusieurs millions de
doses et dans le dans le sprint dans
laquelle on est je pense que c'est pas
négligeable et je ne comprends pas ce
principe de précaution pour le coup
pousser à l'absurde sur ce sujet
fouillis et puis il ya quand même une
chose par rapport à la vaccination c'est
qu'on arrive à un niveau de complexité
on vous dit si vous avez une dose
astrazeneca maintenant vous aurez une
deuxième dose qui sera pas astrazeneca
jeu sera par exemple files heures en
fonction de votre âge comment voulez
vous que les gens s'y retrouvent
il ya un discours très simple très clair
à tenir sur la vaccination sur ce qui se
passe sur la capacité à protéger par
exemple ce vaccin qui est maintenant
considéré astrazeneca comme un vaccin
maudits camps celui qui protège le plus
avec une dose donc il ya des choses
qu'on n'entend pas du côté même du corps
médical et des scientifiques qui sont en
en tant que l'anxiété partout et de la
complication
moi je pense qu'il ya un truc sur la
simplicité on est quand même le pays de
pasteur on arrêtera de nous le dire
et bercy le fait de placer et bien il
faut y aller des questions qui sont
posées justement ma chemise pourquoi pas
le spoutnik l'allemagne envisage de
l'autriche l'a achetée l'europe de l'est
aussi à mai mois écoutez je sais pas si
j'ai parfois un petit côté provocateur
mais je n'arrête pas de dire ma vie moi
si j'avais pu avoir ce portique je
l'aurais fait je connais la russie j'ai
travaillé sur une saison france-russie
je connais la grande culture
scientifique de ce pays je pense que
c'est un bon vaccin
après je pense qu'à des éléments
géopolitiques évidemment diplomatique
dans ce qui est en train de se passer
sur 100 nomo location en europe et je
pense que renaud muselier
il a une stratégie de francs tireurs
mais la qualité de scouts nick moi je
suis prête à dire que je pense qu'elle
est bonne oui de plusieurs plusieurs
choses peut être des paroles qu'on va
donner à nos internautes ch des saluts
et notamment christian léon toujours
fidèle au poste et que les mots gentils
salim également qui le dit il faudrait
au moins on rouvrir toutes les activités
en extérieur dont nous savons qu'elles
ne présente que très peu de risques pour
un semblant de reprise c'est à peu près
votre point de vue j'ai perdu je pense
qu'il est il absurde de continuer à
interdire cette activité en extérieur et
idem pour les piscines puisque
apparemment on a prouvé dans une enquête
britannique je crois a montré que le
chlore effectivement détruisez bien vu
c'est que du coup dans les piscines n'y
avait aucun risque d'attraper le virus
est effectivement c'est que le le sport
a un impact positif justement sur la
santé et peut que souvent les gens qui
meurent du corps et d'un virus sont des
cons aux radicaux morbidité due au
surpoids et c'est donc évidemment il
faut essayer de reprendre tout ce qui
peut l'être sans beaucoup de danger on a
aujourd'hui suspendu beaucoup trop
d'activités et on est je pense
il faudrait comparer pays bas pays mais
je pense que dans le continu des mesures
aidants et dans la généralisation des
mesures la france est quand même allé
très très loin par rapport à d'autres
pays européens en espagne où les salles
de sport elles sont ouvertes en italie
vous avez du stop and go où ça a été
vraiment été continue on n'a pas eu un
restaurant ouvert depuis octobre pas pas
une terrasse pas une salle de sport et
je crois qu'on là dessus on a vraiment
des gouvernants qui ne veulent prendre
aucun aucun risque qu'ils n'ont pas pris
beaucoup de décisions courageuses face
aux variants brésilien à britannique
nous dit skype ainsi que la hausse des
chiffres un vrai confinement plus
strictes comme lors du premier paraît
nécessaire parce que ce non moi je pense
pas je pense que en revanche cette
question de comment est-ce qu'on lutte
contre l'arrivée du variant brésilien
est un point essentiel parce que pour
l'instant c'est faible très faible même
mais encore une fois on sait très bien
qu'il suffit pas d'interdire l'avion
pour que ça ne se diffuse pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans un pays qui
est globalisé qui est mondial
et qu'on peut passer par ailleurs et
c'est donc il ya un sujet de quarantaine
ce que je voulais dire aussi pour réagir
à ce que dit de pas convaincu par la
suspension des vols dans les îles de
presse comprend pas du tout je pense que
pour le coup il fallait tracer et qu'il
fallait confiné mais faire de la
quarantaine sur la question de la
prudence des gouvernants je pense qu'on
est aussi un pays ça a été dit mille
fois mais où il ya une telle méfiance à
l'égard du politique que l'inquiétude
des procès on sait qu'il ya déjà sur mon
plein de côté déposé contre les
politiques accentue encore la difficulté
à surmonter l'hésitation entre
l'économique le sanitaire le
psychologique etc
mais il ya une espèce de négligence qui
est fait sur le fait que ça abîme
psychologiquement de rester chez soi et
c'est d'ailleurs un article qui paraîtra
demain une enquête de agnès leclerc
justement dans les ehpad et le problème
justement que fait peser les mesures de
restriction et ans par jour même de son
maxi et maxi et qui ne seraient toujours
pas sans rien dire
et justement c'est ce que raconte agnès
leclerc donc à retrouver dans les
prochaines dans la prochaine édition du
figaro qui va apparaître dans les
prochaines heures sur l'histoire
justement de la quarantaine et de la
suspension des vols lui s'il est pas
convaincu c'est votre cas aussi moi je
pense surtout qu'on aurait dû le faire
plus tôt et
on a attendu quand même un laps de temps
une dizaine de jours avant de suspendre
ses vols
comme si encore une fois il y avait une
barrière psychologique à la fermeture
des frontières alors qu'on a pu très
facilement sur le bouton quand il s'agit
d'interdire les gens de sortir de chez
eux ou dans un périmètre de 10 km je
pense qu'il ya vraiment il ya quelque
chose de psychologique sida on
la cie la libre circulation des
frontières c'est un espèce de dogme
auquel il faut pas toucher et c'est
effectivement on a mis beaucoup de temps
beaucoup trop de temps la date du 15 mai
représente l'espoir c'est nécessaire
pour un peuple bibis donner des faux
espoirs risquent d'entraîner de plus en
plus de désobéissance petit 74e c'est un
pseudonyme et c'est
sur utilisation le site du figaro je
pense qu'on doit d confiner les gens et
les commerces mais rester vigilants sur
les frontières donc rester confiné au
niveau national et juste pour moi je
pense que c'est avec un confinement
strict c'est un bas si enfin est-ce
qu'on peut le mettre en place
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus mettre en
place c'est à dire qu'il ya plus de
prendre un confinement il faut naître
sur une adhésion de la population comme
vous pourriez confinement ceram par la
peur donc la plupart des ouvriers
indiens pays dictatorial comme l'avait
datchy et la chine mais aujourd'hui on
n'a même pas les moyens de mettre un
juge juste un dernier point un génie ce
matin dans le figaro publié une
interview de jean claude kaufmann
il pointe une fatigue de la liberté en
occident est ce que cette mise en doute
des réouvertures à partir du 15 mai tout
ce bruit médiatique que d'en parler tout
à l'heure lucile n'est pas un symptôme
de cette fatigue de la liberté alors
s'intéressant à ce que jean-claude
kaufmann café un livre qui s'appelle
c'est fatigant la liberté il analyse un
peu ce moment en occident ont finalement
nous avons finalement le culte des
libertés individuelles en démocratie
nous pensons que nous sommes libres de
tout choisir sur l'édition ce que nous
mangeons comment nous nous habillons il
faut sans cesse notamment des multiples
choix à faire et finalement cette
expérience du premier confinement qui le
décrit cette suspension des libertés où
paradoxalement l'individu s'est laissé
aller une forme de il a accepté il a
abandonné sa liberté presque avec un
lâche soulagement parce qu'enfin on
était guidé par un grand récit collectif
avec des contraintes imposées et ils
expliquent comme ça la d22 sens moins de
moins de choix mais plus voilà au moins
voilà exactement hilaire il existe tout
ça de l'adhésion fièrement d'une grande
partie des populations à la restriction
des libertés qui peut paraître paradoxal
en démocratie et c'est une espèce de
fatigue d'être soi qui a été qui a été
on a accueilli finalement ce premier
confirmant comme un soulagement et
encore aujourd'hui on voit dans les
sondages que les français sont
majoritairement favorables aux
restrictions
jean claude kaufmann la fatigue d'être
soi et on va demander à julie de mettre
l'article interview juste en vous faites
dans le chat au moins sur le site du
figaro c'est un festival de alors pardon
je vous donne quand même
puisque j'ai parlé de tweets la réponse
à la question ce qu'on pose sur twitter
la date du 15 mai est elle trop
optimiste pour des confiner la france et
vous répondez oui à 57 % non 43% je vous
demande de ne pas refaire le débat sur
des petits moules pessimisme des
français on l'a fait avec alexis brézet
et jean louis bourlanges
mardi il est à dernier et c'était
effectivement pas très réjouissant sur
le business des français mais il ya
cette phrase très belle de jean louis
bourlanges qui disait que selon lui la
france était cap les français montrent
qu'ils sont capables de faire de gros
sacrifices
c'est un festival de tweets indignés ou
ironique
depuis 48 heures en cause un tweet d'
excuses de la marque evian les community
managers de la célèbre marque ont
demandé pardon pour un tweet précédent
appelant à boire un litre d'eau par jour
et des activistes avaient dénoncé ce
premier tweet
rt si vous avez déjà bu un litre d'eau
aujourd'hui alors pour les plus de 20
ans comme moi et arte c'est à dire aux
tweets et donc des activistes ont
dénoncé dans un tweet anti ramadan ce
qui a soulevé l'indignation ce matin de
la secrétaire d'état
sarah elle eri c'est dingue et en même
temps ça dit quelque chose de notre pays
twitter n'est pas la vraie vie twitter
n'est pas la vraie le la vraie pensée
des français il se trouve que sur
twitter il y à une sorte de deux sphères
islamo gauchistes qui volontairement
pouces et bien à l'art pesant à la
repentance à la victimisation et ont
réussi à faire douter evian c'est ça qui
est dingue et m'ont franchement j'en
suis j'en suis triste
en fait de sept de ses excuses
vous partagez cette tristesse lucide
elle un peu surjouée la tristesse en
revanche cette question des excuses et
du fait qu'il faut qu'ils aient toujours
une lecture politique des choses ça ça
me laisse perplexe en fait mais ça
montre bien qu'on est dans un monde où
chacun et sur son segment en fait sur
son couloir de nage c'est à dire qu'en
fait si vous êtes musulman ou fait
forcément le ramadan donc vous buvez pas
il ya des musulmans qui font pas le
ramadan et y en a peut-être qui boivent
de l'eau voilà donc à une espèce de
manière de vous insérer dans un groupe
et dans votre couloir de nage et enfoncé
samoa kivu dont je souffre le plus et
l'idée de s'excuser en permanence est
aussi une manière d'éviter le débat
c'est ça que je voudrais dire c'est à
dire que d'une certaine manière je pense
que si on gagnerait pour avoir un projet
de société commun à assumer nos
contradictions à débattre à ne pas être
d'accord et à un moment a tranché
donc moi ça me laisse mal à l'aise après
je suis mal placé pour parler de twitter
étant donné que je choisi volontairement
de ne jamais y aller parce que l'idée de
jeu peut-être trop vaniteuse mai mais
l'idée qu' en 140 caractères je vais
trouver quelque chose d'intéressant à
dire ne me séduit pas donc je suis mal
placé pour parler d'eux
ça vous excuserez pas mais vous en
débattre et ça tombe bien parce que
c'est à peu près de la ligne de cette
émission
eugénie oui alors on peut dire c'est que
cette affaire est une tempête dans un
verre d'eau minérale mais je pense
qu'elle révèle quand même quelque chose
c'est à dire qu'effectivement on voit de
plus en plus les grandes marques des
grandes multinationales s'engouffrer
dans ce qu'on appelle le oak hills c'est
à dire cette espèce de deux
d'hypersensibilité aux discriminations
cette volonté de ne pas offenser
et finalement en fait on voit bien
comment ça marche parce que
effectivement la politique on appelle la
politique d identité qu'ils font c'est
finalement à accentuer les différences
entre les individus
elle fait vendre aussi c'est à dire que
le marché est bien content aussi d'avoir
des segments de marché vous êtes un vous
êtes un musulman va vous vendre un hijab
de sport vous êtes 1 1
enfin les membres d'une gbt on va vous
vendre des glaces qui font la promotion
des gb thé etc
enfin voilà on fait comme ça on a des
segments et ça crée des nouveaux
segments et donc le marché est très
content et on voit de plus en plus ces
grandes marques s'engouffrer dans sept 7
dans cette espèce de mouvance
progressiste et c'est amusant parce que
on pourrait se dire enfin les grandes
marques généralement était plutôt rétive
à l'idéologie
on n'a jamais vu des marques fait la
promotion du communisme bizarrement mais
là le capitalisme je suis donc bien que
c'est pas le fait des rocs
oui c'est vrai mais c'est pas cessé pas
très dérangeant parce qu'en fait
finalement ça ne remet pas en question
la structure économique où les
injustices et les inégalités économiques
et c'est une manière de pour les marques
de faire ce qu'on appelle en anglais le
virtus signal inc c'est le signalement
vertueux c'est montrer que finalement on
est du bon côté de l'histoire
on est progressiste facilement on
s'achète une bonne conscience
progressiste en envoyant des signaux
d'inclusivité alors qu'en réalité on
fait fabriquer ses t-shirts en chine
sens où on pollue ou et c est en fait
c'est une bonne manière d'acheter
facilement de la conscience et donc le
capitalisme mondialisé accentue c'était
cette idéologie là alors qu'elle ne
représente pas grand monde en réalité
alors je voulais vous poser une autre
question de questions subsidiaires je
les sors quand même si ce qui s'est
passé avec evian n'est pas le symptôme
d'un autre phénomène finalement d'une
prise d'assaut du capitalisme par les
enfants terribles du gauchisme c'est en
tout cas la question qu'on se pose en
écoutant ce matin l'interview de mathieu
bock côté chez sonia mabrouk sur europe
1 ce n'est plus une exclusivité les
campus américains que ce discours là il
est présent dans les grandes entreprises
about coca-cola coca-cola tour des
salons je donne un exemple propose un
séminaire à ses employés pour leur
apprendre à devenir moins blanc leur
apprendre à devenir on dort ceux des
blancs scheer avère tout cela mais c'est
le fantasme de la guerre des races dans
les guerres la guerre des as c'est un
aspect de l'idéologie book la
quintessence c'est la quintessence du
capitalisme au service de la
quintessence du gauchisme non mais c'est
ce que je disais oui c'est vrai que je
pense que il ya déjà il ya un effet de
mode c'est à dire qu'il ya beaucoup dans
les noms
grandes firmes internationales on veut
dans l'air du temps et comme ces
idéologies sur la mode on les embrasse
il ya une espèce de culpabilité aussi
parce qu'effectivement on est des
grandes entreprises capitalistes on est
du côté des méchants normalement les
capitalistes voilà les grands patrons
etc
donc on veut se racheter en faisant du
progressisme voilà c'est facile et on se
souvient d'ailleurs c'est intéressant de
voir le mouvement black l'animateur a
été soutenu par l'intégralité des
multinationales américaines y en a pas
une qui n'a pas soutenu et même après la
mort de georges floyd hubert ritz qui
n'est entreprise qui exploite ses
employés a fait a rendu les frais
livraison gratuits pour les restaurants
noir à part qui appartenait à des noirs
donc voilà on est vraiment typiquement
de cette politique identitaire limite du
racialisme en renvoyant un message en
garde est on est on est on est des
gentils on est du côté des anti racistes
alors qu'en réalité
donc c'est très bien que c'est une
entreprise qui n'a aucun respect du
droit social qui exploite ses employés
etc
donc on voit bien que ce paradoxe cela
et c'est une manière moi je pense pour
ses grandes entreprises de se racheter
une conscience facilement cet internaute
nous demande si on a le droit de parler
du gauchisme la loi de parler de tout
chers internautes ne soyez pas si
désappointé comme vous le dites en tout
cas c'est le titre c'est le nom de votre
de votre d'autres pseudonymes votre
votre point de vue justement sur sa sur
ces vous pensez que c'est une hypocrisie
finalement tu sais je pense que mathieu
bock côté à tort de toujours pointé le
gauchisme et ses intrigues un prisme qui
là mais je pense qu'effectivement le
capitalisme pour rejoindre génie doit
changer on sait très bien que les
entreprises ne pourront plus transformé
de la même manière ne plus faire leur
profit de la même manière et que là il
ya une espèce d esquive être assez
pathétique à travers
l'instrumentalisation de d'émotion
identitaire et je pense que ça ne peut
pas coller après je pense que ça ne
trompe personne pour être franche c'est
à dire que je pense que quand vous êtes
salarié de ce genre d'entreprise vous
savez à quoi vous en tenir qu'en
revanche ça peut faire partie du
politiquement correct interne à
l'entreprise pour faire carrière de s'y
prêter
je crois que c'est une manière au fond
de vous faire dépendre encore davantage
du politiquement correct et que l'on
vérifie que vous êtes dans une forme de
soumission par rapport à ce
politiquement correct parce qu'on sait
très bien qu'il ya une pression
aux résultats dans ces groupes et on
sait très bien que par exemple quand
emmanuel faber ou isabelle kocher sont
virés d'anji ou de danone
ça traduit et qu'on nous explique qui
sont caractériels ça traduit certes le
fait qu'il voulait assumer des positions
peut-être une façon un peu autoritaire
j'emploie beaucoup dans le mot cette
fois ci mais qu'il y avait aussi envie
de transformer l'objectif la mission de
l'entreprise
donc c'est ça le sujet le sujet c'est
que on est au delà du politiquement
correct du tweet il faut transformer
profondément le capitalisme vous dites
que mathieu bock-côté acteurs de voir le
gauchisme partout mais quand il pointe
justement le racialisme vaut pas
gauchiste c'est ça que je veux dire
hélas hélas en tous les cas pour avoir
le point de vue mathieu bock côté fini
sera pas reporté son livre la révolution
racialiste ça vient de sortir et ça sort
aujourd'hui justement et c'est aux
presses de la cité il nous reste peu de
temps je donne vos commentaires c'est
nous dit cet internaute surtout
commerciale rien à voir l'engouement
black l'armateur pour comprendre que ce
mouvement est tout sauf antisystème
quand il se proclame cet autre
internaute sur le figaro le optimisme
s'est installée de façon insidieuse une
ambiance d'égocentrisme de
susceptibilité excessive et
culpabilisatrice qui va finir par nous
étouffer est-ce qu'on peut juste
j'aurais dû commencer par ça redéfinir
l'idéologie ou qu on peut nommer au qui
ça vient du dollar goa mai
américain éveillé ça veut dire quelqu'un
qui est éveillé qui est en fait
conscientiser conscient de sur les
discriminations qu'ils subissent sur les
discriminations qui fait subir et qui
donc en fait il ya quelque chose de
nouveau kabila religieux d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un basculement une
conversion quasiment du regard et qui
consiste en une hypersensibilité aux
discriminations qui sont parfois micro
micro agression ou invisibles et qui
donc abouti à une lecture du monde
intégralement sur le prisme de ces
discriminations et de sept divisions
dominant-dominé et mon avis d'une équipe
du mans très dangereuse et parce que
extrême extrêmement conflictuel
en réalité les grandes entreprises ne
sont influencés nous dira l'un que parce
qu'il peut leur rapporter de l'argent ou
éviter de leur en faire perdre
et après tout c'est une définition assez
assez consensuelle du capitalisme et de
la loi de l'offre et de la demande
on pourra en débattre un autre jour
merci beaucoup
on vous libère lucile pour aller
remettre le grand prix du livre et du
roman et écologique
la question qu'on me pose est quand même
sur twitter les grandes entreprises sont
elles trop influencée par les idéologies
walk et pour vous c'est tellement week
je n'arrive même pas à voir le nombre de
wii c'est à 80 et 87 % la fois que
j'achète des lunettes pour voir aussi
loin sur l'écran de retour du figaro en
citant quand on termine avec etienne
n'est pas sain pour les marques
d'imposer certaines idées même bonne il
faut laisser libre pensée à la société
et bien c'est sur cette ode à la liberté
qu'on va se quitter on se donne rendez
vous demain même heure même endroit
on rappelle quand même au passage la
revue esprit la dernière livraison à se
procurer et à lire également la guerre
des idées
et c'est d'oublier c'est aux éditions
robert laffont ont bien entendu on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
avec ça j'ai pas oublier guillaume
roquette qui recevra guillaume bernard
et fergane ziari a très vite sur le
figaro et sur fear alive
[Musique]